[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous bonjour et
bienvenue dans sénat streams votre
rendez vous hebdomadaire avec public
sénat
on a le plaisir de recevoir un sénateur
ou une sénatrice qui va répondre à vos
questions et cette semaine j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir sur ce plateau
pierre jean verzeaux laine bonjour
bonjour ça va très bien bien y arriver
merci de l'invitation mais merci à lui
d'avoir accepté notre invitation très
content de vous accueillir on va passer
une heure ensemble on va apprendre à
vous connaître vous êtes sénateur de
l'aisne et vous siéger au sein du groupe
les indépendants république et
territoires on en parlera tout à leur
bonjour à vous surtout si vous nous
regardez on est sur twitter bonjour
aussi à vous si vous nous regardez sur
public sénat le canal 13 de la tnt alors
plein de sujets que je que les
internautes voulait aborder avec vous
parce que c'est bien eux qui m'ont fait
remonter leurs questions et leurs sujets
de préoccupation on va parler de vous on
va faire votre portrait mais avant ça je
voudrais qu'on aborde un sujet
d'actualité si je puis dire un sujet
d'actualité un peu chaude c'est parti
pour le moment actu alors l'actualité au
parlement cette semaine on en parle
beaucoup c'est le vote en première
lecture à l'assemblée nationale de la
fameuse loi confortant les principes
républicains la loi contre le
séparatisme islamistes voulue par le
président de la république dès l'automne
dernier ça y'est l'assemblée nationale a
voté la première lecture et maintenant
c'est à votre tour vous les sénateurs
c'est quoi pour votre esprit avoue
pierre jean verzeaux l'aisne dans quel
état d'esprit êtes vous voilà par
rapport à cette loi vous l'attendait de
pied ferme vous en avez pas trop envie
vous êtes comment écouter le
gouvernement propose un projet de loi on
va on va le regarder et à la question
est ce que dans certains lieux de culte
est ce que dans des certains lieux
d'enseignement s contre l'anglais lieux
publics
est ce que dans certains endroits dans
certains quartiers en france
est ce que les principes républicains
sont pas forcément respectée la réponse
c'est que oui donc est-ce qu'il faut une
loi qui se préoccupent le sujet oui
après ce que la loi répond à toutes les
difficultés
sûrement pas en tout cas ça va plutôt
dans le bon sens il est évident que sur
ce sujet il faut il faut agir mais c'est
loin
ce type de loi ça fait quand même
plusieurs années que ça revient d'une
manière ou d'une autre la vie il faut
c'est de l'appliquer voilà sexy on a
juste communication de bas il ya quand
même un vrai souci d'application entre
ce qui est voté ce qui est ce qui est
respectée ensuite il ya un gap et il
faut pas se louper de ce côté là est-ce
que c'est judicieux de la part du
gouvernement de proposer cette loi en ce
moment compte tenu du contexte c'est
aussi critiqué sa du côté du
gouvernement on est en pandémie mondiale
la crise économique crise sanitaire
bon voilà il ya un certain nombre de
sujets sur le tapis qui sont peut-être
un peu plus urgent est ce que le
gouvernement a raison de s'attaquer au
problème
ou est ce qu'elle n'aurait plus parce
que c'est un sujet de société oui c'est
la pandémie
ok d'accord on a quand même le droit de
travailler le droit de s'occuper des
sujets qui transperce la société
française moi ça me choque pas que ce
soit dans le débat aujourd'hui
pas du tout ok d'accord il ya petits
cailloux voulais vous poser la question
quel est votre avis sur la droitisation
du débat politique en france
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement a raison de débattre avec
l'extrême droite
alors vous parlez du débat darmanin le
pen lorsque ça fait référence le fait
que voilà mise de l'intérieur débat avec
la candidate du racing en national en
direct à la télévision une heure de
grande écoute
je vous en pensez-quoi pierre-jean
verlaine déjà alors pour tous ceux qui
sont élus ou passionné de politique
ce débat il a fait beaucoup parler leur
caste médiatique a beaucoup fait de
bruit pendant quelques jours quand on
regarde les chiffres d'audience c'était
pas terrible
c'est un passionné les foules moins de 2
millions de téléspectateurs un peu moins
de 2 millions
et moi quand je me balade dans la rue ce
week end j'ai personne qui m'a parlé de
ce débat là donc faut prendre ça aussi
pour faut prendre ça pour pour ce que
c'est mais après qu'un ministre de
l'intérieur débattent avec la présidente
d'un parti qui souvent arrive en tête
aux élections
il n'y a rien de choquant enfin c'est
discutable georges jacques chirac avait
refusé de débattre avec jean marie le
pen en 2002 fut un temps où c'était pas
acceptable est ce que c'est ça qui a
changé la droitisation dont parle petit
caillou dans sa question est-ce que
c'est pas ça et qu'est ce qu'on appelle
la droite is sure du double fait faux
leur assemblée nationale est devenu un
parti acceptable et la verbalisation de
marine le pen at elle fonctionné
vous avez les électeurs qui aux
élections européennes à des élections
régionales à une élection présidentielle
place marine le pen tout en haut
c'est si on débattait pas avec si on
échangeait pas comment ça me choquerait
jamais de problème a dit m
aucun donc pour vous y at il une
pertinence à ce que c'est alex qui vous
pose cette question pertinence du parti
des républicains
coincée entre la république en marche
qui se droitise et le ratio national et
ce qui reste un espace politique selon
vous pour la droite la droite
alors si on rentre dans des sujets très
très politique déjà sur le côté est ce
que le front national
qu'est ce que le front national incarne
aujourd'hui au clair à l'époque de jean
marie le pen
je pense qu'ils sont allés pardon parler
comme ça a dit d'aller manger les parts
de marché de la droite qui avait
abandonné un certain nombre de sujets ok
ensuite marine le pen quand elle a pris
les rênes du mouvement el al est parti
sur autre chose
elle est allée chercher les déçus les
déçus de la gauche est elle est allée
pardon mais manger de l'électorat à
gauche et c'est d'ailleurs été la
bouffée d'oxygène qu'elle a eue qui ont
permis au front national de faire des
premiers tours de passer de 15 à 22 23
24 25
donc ça n'est plus forcément qu'un parti
d'extrême droite ça reste un parti
extrême qui pas qui à un moment a été
chercher de la droite et qui à un moment
a été chercher des électeurs de gauche
et alain discours qui est extrêmement
branché sur le social alors je sais pas
si c'est bon ou d'ailleurs mais quand on
écoute marine le pen
d'ailleurs elle parle même pas tellement
celui qui bosse c'est à dire celui qui
est au smic à 1200 euros qui se lève
tous les matins elle lui parle pas
tellement elle pas plutôt celles qui
travaillent pas d'ailleurs il ya tout à
face et tout ça sont des réflexions très
respecté en termes de part de marché
c'est donc voilà ce que représente le
front national sur sur le comment sur le
côté est ce que les républicains en
quelque chose à jouer
et bien sûr que oui et les républicains
comme les autres
je veux dire sur des sujets régaliens
sur des sujets économiques
mais après la politique et d'ailleurs
c'est l'expérience que j'en fais elle
s'incarne dans des femmes et dans des
hommes et ce qu'il faut c'est des
leaders des gens qui tique que les
français ont envie d'écouter et que ces
gens là tentent d'apporter ce que
voulait dire le manque de deux figures
tutélaires de dérives du parti les
républicains pour le dire clairement
participe aussi de son effacement serre
si ce que vous dites c'est que s'ils
avaient un homme ou une femme qui
représentait le parti républicain face à
emmanuel macron face à marine le pen
alors on pourrait on parlerait moins de
deux ans qui incarne une forme d'espoir
pour la suite
mais laisser faire les choses à la thur
auto a horreur du vide donc est ce que
l'islam va être un sujet central de
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
selon vous ce que vous pensez qu'on va
t'on on va on va avoir un débat public
qui va tourner autour de ce sujet là
plus que d autres s'avéra parti ça fera
évidemment partie des sujets parce que
enfin le sujet c'est pas c'est pas
tellement l'islam en tant que tel
le sujet c'est l'art a dit que la
radicalisation d'une partie de la
société de mauvaises habitudes de
comportement qui ne sont pas acceptables
qu'il faut dont il faut s'occuper
il ya ça milliers d'e-mails août sujet
attendait le sujet de la reprise
économique
le sujet de la france des territoires le
sujet du coc vide ou de la vaccination
qui certes est encore enfin les sujets y
seront multiples ça fera partie des
sujets sur d'accord et qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la polémique autour de la
ville de trappes
ces derniers jours est ce qu'on est dans
une hystérisation du débat qui est
inutile ou est-ce qu'au contraire c'est
une vraie et c'est une réalité dont il
faut parler il faut pas se voiler la
face comment vous voyez les choses je
connais pas le j'ai lu comme tout le
monde quelques articles je connais pas
je connais pas le fond des choses qu'un
comment quinquin enseignants face est
enseignant il a le droit de dire ce
qu'il veut en france on est libre on
parle on parle comme on le souhaite
donc il est que sa liberté de parole
soit respectée le maire de trappes aussi
le droit de défendre sa commune
défendent ce qui s'y passe
je n'ai pas à m'immiscer dans un conflit
j'ai l'impression quelque part qui est
un peu politique localement sur des
choses que je ne maîtrise pas mais
voilà le fond cette enseigne le droit de
parler le maire alors défendre sa
commune le mr ianovski dit on vous sent
pas très choqué par le climat politique
actuel
parce que vous avez un côté défaitiste
bros c'est comme ça c'est pas défaitiste
et on fait avec la réalité
est ce que c'est un sujet qui intéresse
les gens où elle en est ce que c'est un
sujet qui existent dans la société on y
voit donc on en parle et il ya justement
pas que paca qui voudraient vous posez
la question c'est en tant que kelly d'un
dédain d'une zone rurale
est-ce que vous vous sentez concerné par
ces débats publics autour de l'islam
radical
la sécurité tous ces sujets là où est ce
que pour vous c'est un sujet qui me
prouve qu'ils ne concernent que les
urbains alors est-ce que je suis
directement touchés par ce sujet est-ce
que j'ai été élu local
enfin le sénateur vous avez fui les
phénomènes d'insécurité nom assez peu un
vécu des incivilités pas vu qu'il
fermait d'insécurité est ce que on a
vécu une phénomène de d'islamisation
autre chose comme ça la réalité c'est
que non et pourtant les territoires
comme les nôtres e m le front national
tout en haut et beaucoup plus que les
territoires urbains qui eux vivent sa
mixité qui eux vivent ces difficultés
certains ça veut dire que c'est des
sujets qui touchent les jambes et c'est
un paradoxe alors ça les touche sans les
toucher et c'est totalement paradoxe
pour plusieurs raisons déjà quand vous
quand vous vivez la réalité quand vous
vivez les choses ça se dégonfle assez
naturellement skis et ski ski ce qui
fait monter les peurs c'est quand je ne
connaissais pas les choses
quand vous les voyez de loin il ya ce
phénomène là et de il y à un autre il ya
un autre phénomène
et ça c'est phénomène du déclassement
d'une partie de la ruralité qui
globalement quand elle ouvre le journal
local regarde la télé a pas l'impression
de faire partie du film si vous voulez
dans des bandes plus ya des difficultés
il ya des souffrances c'est à dire c'est
clair on lui conteste pas j'ai faim je
les conteste pas mais par contre j'ai on
m'en parle
voyez on en parle depuis le début la
maison dans l'actualité est donc quelque
part
ça fait partie de l'histoire ça fait
partie du film ça fait partie de sue
voilà des échanges
le déclassement ruralité est un sujet
dont on parle peu donc des gens qui
souffrent qui sont déclassées mais ya
pas que ça il ya plein de choses qui
vont bien si vous les maîtres qui seront
déclassés et qui se maintient bien jouer
au grand journal suis pas dedans j'en
étais les je suis pas dedans
les élus je suis pas tellement
représentait pas l'impression d'être
représentés de faire partie du film ça
explique aussi en partie le vote le vote
du front national et et vous savez il
n'y a pas de baguette magique
il n'y a pas de solution à tout mais des
fois la politique c'est juste de mettre
des bons mots sur des sentiments que les
gens ressentent et force est de
constater que ça pas existé depuis de
nombreuses années sur la ruralité
j'en parle on en parle avec avec vous
depuis tout à l'heure parce que le texte
séparatisme va arriver au sénat c'est
pratiquement le gouvernement qui a
décidé que que vous alliez en
parlez-vous les sénateurs ce texte
soulève un certain nombre de sujets des
sujets tendu on parle de l'école on
parle des associations est-ce que vous
en tant que sénateur il ya certains sur
certains c'est cher vous avez
l'intention de vous mobiliser
alors moi moi globalement je trouve que
les sujets qui sont abordés touche
quelque part au vivre ensemble et au
fait enfin au sujet de est-ce que fin
voilà qu'on ne restait dans un espace
républicain dans tout un tas de lieux
qu'on partage les uns les autres
donc je trouve que les sujets abordés
sont plutôt les bonzes après j'ai pas
encore lu je vais pas vous la faire
comme on dit et on va lui j'ai pas lu
tout où le texte en détail en tout cas
l'ensemble des sujets qui sont abordés
me paraissent être cohérent on verra
bien ce à écouter à de suivre justement
les débats au sénat je sais qu'en tout
cas les différents groupes
parlementaires se commence à s'en saisir
depuis quelques depuis quelques jours si
je me permets il ya un volet par contre
je pense qu'on va passer loin du tout
mais c'est un sujet qui est pas simple
c'est sur les réseaux sociaux
alors on la haine en ligne le pénaliser
on va augmenter les choses etc
mais dans la luttre contre le terrorisme
mais peut-être pas même jusque là sur
des phénomènes
d'où d'islamisation des esprits de
certains
là pour le coup je crois que les
facebook les google et autre peu en
termes d'information de capacité à
capter ce qu'il est rare chez quelqu'un
ils ont beaucoup à apporter en termes
d'information à l'état français
pensez vraiment que c'est pas quelque
chose qui passe sous les radars mais il
n'y a pas un risque dans ce que vous
dites d'avoir un contrôle étatique des
contenus sur internet
ça vous fait pas peur ça mais celui et
celui qui n'a rien à se reprocher si
vous voulez je vois pas bien ce qu'il a
reproché face qui pourraient craindre de
quoi que ce soit les informations sur
nos vies privées en toute personne qui
utilisent ces réseaux sociaux ces
réseaux sociaux et les ont fait asseoir
des ailes est long mais l'érosion oui
c'est un truc de c'est un truc de fou
vous pensez à quelque chose vous en
parler qu'un ami deux jours après vous
avez la fuite ont embrassé vraiment les
algorithmes eux sont totalement
totalement fou donc ces informations ils
les ont
et qu'il soit contraint de transmettre
là où ça peut représenter un risque pour
la société
ça me paraît juste être le minimum corps
et bien écoutez assure en tout cas ça
suscite quelques réactions dans le chatt
apparemment ils sont pas tout à fait
d'accord avec vous c'est vrai qu'on
prend d'un public d'internautes qui est
plutôt à cheval sur la question de la
sécurité et de la protection des
libertés sur internet donc l'idée qu'un
quatre sénateurs disent qu'on pourrait
toucher aux réseaux sociaux sur lutte
contre la radicalité c'est vrai que ça
peut faire peur mais mais mais ces mêmes
internautes à partir du moment où ils
vont se connecter à facebook instagram
et à google est ce qu'on veut mais les
informations ces groupes là les on est
sur les mêmes groupes privés et que
quelques saisons les choses alors
attendez pour le coup pour le coup je
trouve qu'il faudrait qu'on aille
beaucoup plus long terme de l'isla sûr
mais là on oublie sujet l'avant pour
savoir exactement quelles données il
possède sur les uns les autres
qu'est-ce qu'ils gardent combien de
temps comment il est et face et quand
ils les vendent à d'autres qu'est ce
qu'ils vendent
comment et combien ça c'est un immense
sujet de société
d'accord on va parler de vous maintenant
pierre jean verzeaux l'aisne on va
apprendre à vous connaître c'est le
moment du portrait alors dites moi un
petit peu pierre-jean vermeulen qu'elle
alors j'ai des questions assez classique
mais on a quand même envie de savoir
quel bac vous avez fait j'ai fait un bac
es et je les louper une fois celles à
l'oral c'est à dire ta paix gelé pas
annoncer rattrapage et je les passe non
mais je suis le rattrapage je n'ai pas
eu un rattrapage à merde et ça démarre
et droite pour moi d'ailleurs c'était
sur le sujet de la parité
ces deux journées sur la parité si tu
savais
j'étais pas bon et enfin je boite est
bon pour le celui qui va auditionner en
tout cas et donc j'ai passé le bac
l'année la presse ou les faire quoi plus
tard mais moi j'ai oscillé entre plein
de métiers c'est bien ça
citons en étant très jeune je voulais
faire le tour du monde à la voile le
voile est skipper met en mode vraiment
c'est un truc génial m'occuper beaucoup
l'esprit
ok j'ai voulu être journaliste ouais ça
arrive à des gens bien chez sa rivale
j'étais passionné de radio au coût de la
radio europe 1 donc je lisais les
journaux maintenant fait c'est ce qui
m'a amené à la politique sa valise et
beaucoup l'actualité le matin énormément
et je faisais la revue de presse je
faisais monsieur gros sur à l'époque qui
invitera sur europe 1 et donc je je je
je je je
j'ai voulu faire ça et puis ensuite eu
partie dans des études bons échos
sociaux je suis parti faire une école de
commerce vous avez fait l'edhec
effectivement ce qu'ils avaient plus
directement à voir avec le l'engagement
politique
une par contre j'étais militant dans un
mouvement politique j'étale est alors
environ reviendra sur votre sur votre
engagement politique mais dont vous avez
fait une école de commerce
quel souvenir est ce que vous en gardez
vous êtes content d'être passé par là
vous aurais préféré faire de
l'université sam dans la région des dix
3-1 peut en poser les questions ou est
ce que c'est bon ça le sens comique de
jeunes ya les exclusions responsable je
me suis pas épanoui complètement ok à
tout vous dire le l'enseignement était
intéressant c'était très pratico
pratique
par contre l'ambiance est comme ça pas
été trop mon truc
merci vraiment vous l'écran dans les
détails de ma vie j'étais dans l'aisne
je suis fils d'agriculteur j'ai
énormément d'amis agriculteurs qui
partait dans une école d'agriculture à
lille donc j'ai beaucoup vécu avec eux
les soirs et les week-ends plutôt
qu'avec les jambes on décolle donc avec
des copains en école d'agriculteurs
hockey un angle c'est intéressant c'est
intéressant
est ce que vous comprenez les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui leur mal être et leur
souffrance sur un point de vue social la
précarité mais aussi du point de vue du
suivi de leurs études vous imaginez vous
suivre en visio vos cours un petit
moment peut-être mais le jeu comprend ce
phénomène d'isolement qui à la longue
doit être doit être plus que pénible
j'entends que sur un plan financier
celui qui avait ses petits boulots pour
financer pour financer ses études ou les
à côtés il ya plus ex est extrêmement
extrêmement compliqué d'ailleurs les
chiffres qui sont tout à fait des images
qui sont inquiétantes
des chiffres qui sont qui sont tout à
fait inquiétant j'ai pas non plus envie
moi de parler de 2,2 forcément de
génération sacrifiée c'est pas une
génération qu'on a trouvé cette fille
est important comme mots je trouve cela
important parce qu'il ya personne je
pense qu'il fondamentalement a voulu les
sacrifiés là où j'ai un peu de mal ce
qu'on veut c'est que les bts pour elle
est en étude que les prépas pouvait s'y
rendre alors sur des sur des respectant
certains principes sanitaires et quand
universités enfin même les td s'était
pas autorisés à une époque où
visiblement les
ça se s'assouplit un peu est ce que vous
comprenez aussi le sentiment parfois que
certains jeunes expriment de ne pas être
entendus ou compris par la classe
politique par leurs représentants par
les parlementaires
cette idée que on parle beaucoup des
ehpad on parle beaucoup des commerçants
parlent beaucoup de tout un tas de gens
dont c'est important de parler les
étudiants ça arrive à la toute fin quand
quand on sent qu'on tient c'est vrai
qu'on a pas donné la parole à feu à la
ministre combien naissance mais je le
comprends parce qu'effectivement on n'en
a pas parlé pendant plusieurs est par
contre le fait est qu'il suffit qui est
quelquefois un article un sondage ou une
image et la société médiatique
s'engouffre dans le sujet là depuis
trois semaines un mois on en parle on en
parle pas mal la preuve c'est qu'on va
effectivement très peu parlé depuis le
début après sur le côté en se manifeste
pas on n'est pas représenté moi je parle
avec beaucoup de gens qui ont
l'impression que les élus les
représentent pas que c'est qu'elle a
l'impression que tout le monde fait mal
je crois pas qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'élus en théorie qui se disent je vais
y aller vraiment pour essayer de rien
quoi je pense qu'en théorie
chacun y va en disant je vais essayer de
faire bien et à ceux qui pensent qu'ils
sont pas représentés on vit dans un truc
formidable qui s'adapte enocre à 6
c'est-à-dire que des élections c'est à
dire que celui qui pense qu'il a un truc
plus intéressant raconté que l'autre
celui qui pense qu'il peut faire mieux
et il peut se présenter à des élections
ça s'appelle la démocratie c'est très
bien en terme de représentativité ans
n'ont pas encore trouvé mieux pour
autant ça reste critiquée comme comme
démocratie y en a beaucoup qui trouve
que c'est pas très démocratique que ça
pourrait l'être encore mieux alors sous
quelle forme
la pros participation alors la question
de la proportionnelle des modes
d'élection la question de la
comptabilisation du vote blanc est là et
la prise en compte pour la prise en
compte du vote blanc et pourquoi pas un
vote obligatoire
la question du tirage au sort la
convention citoyenne pour le climat ya
quand même un certain nombre de sujets
sur la table où la question de
l'amélioration de notre système
politique est porté notamment par des
jeunes
je parlais en termes de systèmes de 20
après ok tout ce qui concourt
comment a donné la parole à écouter des
citoyens oui sur la convention citoyenne
ouais au départ de prime abord j'écoute
le principe je me dis à quoi ça
ressemble ce truc c'est bizarre c'est
quoi ce gadget pachoud vrai pendant les
vacances de noël je m'embête je vais
rencontrer deux personnes donc y
habitent
territorialement pas loin de là où je
suis qui ont participé à la convention
citoyenne
quand j'écoute le fonctionnement alors
ils ont pour eux il ya à prendre et à
laisser si vous voulez un truc très
positif ou négatif
je trouve que la démarche à l'époque en
fait vous êtes le seul sénateur à parce
que j'ai posé des questions sur la
conscience citoyenne à tous les
sénateurs depuis deux ans et demi que je
reçois sur ce plateau
j'ai vu de tous des gens qui trouvent ça
génial des gens qui trouve ça nul
j'ai jamais rencontré des sénateurs qui
a changé d'avis en cours de route en
disant tiens
au début je n'étais pas chaud puis j'ai
rencontré j'ai trouvé ça intéressant ça
fait très intéressant la politique ça
arrive commandant redit à quel moment
raconté moi vous avez commencé à me dire
que vous regardiez vous écoutiez les
infos la revue de presse qu'elle
commence à arriver en janvier la
politique je hais ce qu'à la maison on
en parlait déjà
alors parents pas militant ou quel
parent pas élus parents politiquement
notamment papa plutôt à droite il a fait
la campagne de chirac en 95
il est parti parce qu'il a fait là quand
ça lui a plu ça parle de politique à
table
ouais parquet ça parle beaucoup
politique je le matin j'ai de la chance
je me
m il ya le concurrencer le figaro sur la
droite il se faisait pas mais comme il
est ouvert d'esprit parce que d'acheter
libé le monde donc ça permettait aussi
de s'ouvrir à d'autres à d'autres
journaux donc j'ai une sensibilité à ça
et puis après la politique c'est un truc
de passion quoi et les passions c'est
pas bien pourquoi ça arrive et ça me
passionnait
je vais pas vous dire le cliché de quand
je voyais une soirée électorale
ça me vibrer plus que dans une finale de
coupe du monde peut-être pas à ce point
là
mais en fait je pense à me passionner
quoi ya pas et dans différents il ya
passé un truc parce que parce qu'ils
renonçaient génération beaucoup vous
diront quand j'ai vu le pen au second
tour interprété des chansons jouées ça
je vous dirai pas la vérité ça me
passionnait déjà j'ai pas un élément
j'ai eu un déclic
c'est quelque chose qui me fait vibrer
qui me plaît quoi alors comment ça s'est
passé du coup vous avez fait quoi à quel
âge vous ai dit tiens vous avez poussé
la porte d'un parti politique qui a eu
une manif ça c'est fait comment votre
entrée dans la politique je crois que
quand j'ai 18 ans je me rends à la
permanence parlementaire à saint quentin
à l'époque c'était déjà l'ump
ouais on doit être pourtant ça coïncide
on doit être après l'élection de chirac
en 2002 ouais ou juste avant que je sais
plus et là je suis chez les jeunes pop
et je rencontre quelqu'un de la section
jeunes du parti politique l'ump à
l'époque voilà qu est un truc qui vivait
bien à l'époque et donc je rencontre pas
mal d'autres jeunes qui sont des copains
et qui sont d'ailleurs encore des corps
pas que j'aimerais souvent qu'ils sont
plus forcément du tout en politique et
donc il rend plus quelque chose d'amical
là dedans qui se déclenche et puis
c'était une belle époque alors ça dépend
comment les uns les autres l'ont vécue
mais c'est l'époque à laquelle sarko
comment
nicolas sarkozy pardon de l'intérieur
ouais et part pour sa présidentielle et
on était encore aux pommes il y avait
une dynamique
il y avait une impressionnante à
l'époque avait un truc une 2006 2007 et
donc c'était très c'etait tres été très
prenant et puis ensuite je vends les
études je commence à travailler dans la
banque alors d'ailleurs j'avais une
question pour vous de la part de petite
saab qui voulait savoir fils
d'agriculteur vous avez fait des études
supérieures comment est ce que vous avez
financer vos études petits boulots non
non non non ont fait mes parents qui
paient bien de tuer vous aviez la chance
d'avoir des parents qui pouvaient ok
d'accord tant mieux je fais des jobs
d'été
ok pour moi mais c'est mes parents qui
étaient mes études mais c'est une
question en lien avec la précarité
étudiante en ce moment c'est pour ça que
la question qu'est donc continuer voilà
vous êtes étudiant vous commencé à
bosser du coup après une école de
commerce dans la banque
enfin rien à voir avec la voir ça vous a
plu ou gerry barr dans l'oise
c'était plutôt intéressant ouais c'est
auprès des entreprises auxquelles elles
et les problématiques les gens vus
c'était vrai c'est assez passionnant et
donc je reviens et donc 2014 élections
municipales et moi 2 3 en revanche trop
pourquoi je m'étais fait un schéma je
vais trouver une ville un peu important
je vais faire adjoint touchera bon
c'était un peu parti comme ça et puis
mais après quand je lis je revenais
toujours chez mes parents lui tiennent
bon ben arfa et le et donc je romps et
j'ai été élu conseiller municipal à
mortier 200 habitants mes parents
habitent à côté un chef de canton
crécy-sur-serre 1500 habitants ça peut
paraître très petit pour nous c'est pas
mal et enfin celle où il ya tous les
services et donc le maire arrête je le
vois d'ailleurs à une réunion
bref ça se passe pas très bien entre
nous je vais sais pas trop et quelques
jours après ils démarrent qui dit je
vais installer et donc je me présente au
minimum c'est juste à côté je
connaissais un peu toulon mais est donc
là se sont enchaînées en fait les
générations et donc vous êtes élu maire
à seulement 30 ans je suis élu maire à
30 ans ray et président de la communauté
de communes dans la foulée dans la
foulée et puis un an après l'élection
départements classés super jeune dame et
vous avez l'air de dire que ça s'est
fait comme ça s'est fait comme ça c'est
fait c'est quand même pas rien vous êtes
propulsé mr à 30 ans ça s'est passé
comment alors vous avez découvert du
coup le job de d'élu local
j'ai découvert à ce moment-là et amiens
s'est passé comment dont ça s'est passé
ça s'est passé très bien
déjà bon alors je sais qu'on aime à
parler d'eux en tant que maire les
difficultés ce qui va pas il ya quand
même un côté absolument génial or je
veux dire les gens si vous êtes plutôt
positif plutôt dans la bonne humeur et
vous avez plutôt envie de résoudre des
problèmes que d'encre et les gens vous
renvoie ça et ça se passe en général
très bien
humainement c'est top c'est hyper
enrichissant sur un plan intellectuel
moi je suis pas un très bon bricoleur
j'ai appris comment oser une route
combien ça coûte et un bâtiment à faire
après c'est travailler avec d'autres
gens c'est mais on s'y fait très vite et
celui qui a envie de s'investir et c'est
génial
ouais et est ce que quand vous êtes élu
donc donc mr est ce que vous avez un
boulot à côté
est-ce que vous continuez à travailler
dans le privé ou est-ce que ça devient
votre vie tout de suite c'est toujours
dans la banque vous êtes toujours dans
la banque
ok c'est parce que c'est vrai que j'ai
eu plusieurs questions comme ça de 2,2
d'internautes qui m'ont demandé voilà
quand on se consacre à des mandats
locaux
est ce qu'on est obligé de quitter sa
vie professionnelle ouais je vais vous
raconter une histoire
alors allez-y ce n'est pas une histoire
je travaille dans la banque je suis élu
maire je suis élu président de la
communauté de communes à l'époque je
démissionne de la banque pour reprendre
un cabinet d'assurances le côté alors je
danse dans un groupe d'assurances là je
pars en formation six mois donc vous
arrêtez votre boulot vous savez quel
cabinet vous reprenez chèque de la porte
ou machin bon et entretemps je démarre
la campagne des élections
départementales
ouais et donc à quelques semaines de la
fin je me suis reçue par quelques
directeurs qui m'explique break août
soit tu continues à faire des claquettes
sur les tables en politique à soir-là en
trente ans chaque et tu t'en vas
soit tu continues tu reprends le cabinet
mais t'es mort d'internet
et je prends une décision je reprends
mon chèque je leur apprends par l'agencé
je vais aux élections c'est un mot ça a
été un vendredi où vous avez eu le choix
entre une carrière publique d'élus ouais
de la république vous c'est d'après
toujours à moi c'est ce que j'appelle un
bon choix et on s'était un moment et ce
n'était pas simple histoire de la gagne
donc tout va bien si je la perds je
regrette peut-être ça pendant pendant
très longtemps et quand on parle du
statut de l'élu pour celui qui bosse
dans le privé c'est c'est un problème
lourd
en tout cas moi j'ai touché de près les
limites de soins parce qu'on imagine
qu'il ya tout un tas de pierre jean
verzeaux laine ailleurs en france qui
ont fait un autre choix pour des raisons
différentes voilà qui ont dû dire bon
bah c'est avec la politique j'adore ça
mais je peux pas m'asseoir sur sur ce
boulot sûr peut-être peut-être ou alors
il faut des métiers mais de façon on le
voit encore la sociologie change un peu
maintenant depuis quatre ans mais il y
avait une proportion de gens qui étaient
fonctionnaires qui étaient enseignants
ou des professions libérales des avocats
des médecins ou l'organisation de la vie
permettait 2 d'autres profils c'était
quand même beaucoup plus rares bon on a
parlé de votre encore 3 c'est encore
trop rares dont on a parlé de votre de
votre parcours de vie de comment est ce
que vous êtes devenu élu local
j'ai aussi une question sur votre
positionnement politique vous êtes ou
aujourd'hui vous vous lassez réalisé
sous quelle latitude politiquement vous
êtes toujours proche des républicains
pour vous la faire simple je suis un mec
de droite hockey qui ne croient plus
tellement au fonctionnement des partis
politiques tel qu'il est tel qu'ils
pratiquent aujourd'hui
alors ça se retrouve vous parce que vous
siégez au sein au sénat vont siéger au
sein d'un groupe qui s'appelle les
indépendants république et territoires
pourquoi vous y siéger pas avec les
républicains déjà pendant la campagne je
n'ai pas été chercher d'investiture moi
j'ai construit ma liste je suis allé
toquer à la porte de personnes ce qui
vous met très à l'aise que sa personne
vous dit non vous de votre truc
j'étais président des maires de l'aisne
mais je vais demander soutien d'aucun
d'aucun mouvement politique candidat
indépendant comme on dit j'étais
totalement indépendant et donc de me
retrouver dans un groupe d'indépendants
ce n'était pas un truc totalement
illogique
ensuite je trouve que c'est un groupe à
taille humaine c'est saisir pour se
former c'est pas mal parce qu'on prend
la parole la parole revient souvent
vous intervenez sur tout un tas de
sujets voilà ça me paraissait cohérent
avec ce qui s'était passé avec mon
parcours avec ce qui s'était passé
pendant la campagne je m'éclate bien le
le vous avez dit je suis un mec de
droite qui n'a plus vraiment confiance
dans les partis politiques sur le mode
roi tu sais quoi c'est quoi la droite
pour vous vous êtes tous et c'est quoi
vos valeurs c'est quoi ce que vous
défendez ses couettes de droite en une
21 ses couettes de droit tant de ses
couettes de droite je crois que la
droite par rapport à la gauche parce que
c'est bien comme ça que les choses se
font des amendes est lui personnellement
parlé mais c'est comme ça que ça marche
enfin la base je trouve que la droite
regarde l'être humain tel qu'il est avec
ses défauts et avec ses qualités et il
tient compte de ce qu'est l'être humain
et à partir de ça ils essaient de bâtir
une société
je trouve qu'à gauche il ya une forme
d'angélisme
je sais pas si le terme est bon mais qui
consiste à penser que l'homme est bon
que l'homme est partageur que l'homme
souhaite le bien de son voisin mais
malheureusement on a tous un peu de ça
en nous et on n'a pas que de ça en nous
non plus et je trouve que le le le
regard que la droite porte sur l'homme
tient compte de la réalité de ce qu'est
l'homme
et que donc après c'est plus facile de
2,2 de réformer et d'apporter les bonnes
mesures
ensuite est-ce que la paire à l'histoire
de l'entonnoir
je le sais un principe qui consiste à
dire bon on parle des inégalités dans la
vie ont fui au fur et à mesure du temps
un manteau noir fait enfin dans ce
sens-là fait aller de tourner un peu
plus on donne un peu plus et tout ça
depuis ont aussi l'équivalent trucs et
moi je rêve d'une société mais c'est un
rêve et c'est pour ça que la droite
était beaucoup plus réaliste que la
gauche mais aussi dans une société où au
travail l'égalité des chances c'est à
dire l'entonnoir à l'envers c'est à dire
on essaie de mettre le maximum au tout
début de la vie pour que chacun essaie
de partir à peu près avec les mêmes
chances et qu'on serait plus dans un
phénomène de fatalisme et 2 de
renouvellements sociale voilà moi la
société que mais idéal et je vais en
raison c'était la question que je vous
pose est d'accord donc ça c'est un
format de droite c'est l'égalité des
chances et c'est regarder l'homme tel
qu'il est d'accord
est-ce que c'est pas un peu compatible
avec emmanuel macron ça non je ne suis
pas réellement posé la question est ce
qui est manuel macron n'est pas le cas
le président rêver de la droite
française
quand même mort en tout cas aussi à
l'européen autoritaire franchement
libéral si vous pensez que la droite et
libéral je pense que vous vous trompez
un peu d'ailleurs tous les parcours
libéraux à droite ont jamais été
forcément très loin alors dit les gens
qui étaient libéraux à la base on finit
colbertiste pour les convaincre pour les
convaincre les électeurs
il a alors pourrait on pourrait fausser
vraiment une console vers l'iss après
après on va dire les choses mais diego
les meilleures façons quand il est
arrivé
sa sensibilité à l'économie son côté
mois le président quelle autorité machin
c'est sûr que ça a plus une partie de la
droite c'est évident sur le régalien ça
c'est quand même pas mal décroché sur
l'économie je pense qu'il lui reste la
france qui va bien qui va même très bien
pour le reste ça a été plutôt décevante
il ya vous pensez qu'il ya un décrochage
aussi une partie de son électorat ou
emmanuel macron s'adresse au
centre-ville des winners avec mais il en
dit moins il a faim
je il ya des fractures électorale la
fracture qu'on peut observer depuis
quelques années mais emmanuel macron il
en est l'incarnation ou ce qu'on veut
mais c'est le différentiel de votre
entre les milieux urbain enfin hyper
urbain et les milieux ruraux quand vous
prenez les scores du front national
je veux dire que j'allais de 5 à 50 cc
c'est ça en dit long sur le décalage des
modes de vie la perception des choses
vous avez donc été élu sénateur by assez
peu il ya assez peu de temps réalité
c'est eto'o c'était à l'automne dernier
vous allez nous raconter ses premières
noie ses premiers mois au sénat c'est
parti pour le moment sénat une question
de tomasino qui vous demande ce que vous
pensez du non cumul des mandats est ce
que ça vous manque de ne plus être maire
la proximité avec la population vous
dire le non cumul des mandats c'est une
connerie
ah ouais ouais ouais ouais non mais
alors ça fait
sur papier c'est bien quand on lisait
les sondages tous les français voulaient
le mandat unique que nous serons à
nanterre une au sénateur s'occupe à
plein temps de leur boulot de saynètes
voilà voilà
sauf que les français dans le même temps
où il répondait ça en même temps
réalisés en général des gens qui
cumulent quant aux commandes il va
comprendre hier et l'esprit ce qu'on
leur présente en tout cas visiblement
les uns les autres s'y retrouver alors
évidemment qu'il ya une limite
évidemment que ça parlementaire peut pas
à la fois enfin accumulé cinq six autres
responsabilités
par contre le fait d'être maire d'une
commune de quelques milliers d'habitants
au pouvoir où l'on fixe le seuil est
telle selon les territoires
ça paraît quand même juste la bonne idée
pour rester connecté déjà ce qu'est ce
qui est l'élu garder le sénateur ils
représentent les élus locaux et les
territoires et il peut plus être élu
local mais en responsabilité
c'est un truc fallait y penser je pense
que c'était quand même une bonne idée
pour connecter les gens à la réalité
enfin pour connecter les élus d'accord
que bailleur et d'ailleurs pardon mais
l'enjeu pour les sénateurs pour les pour
les parlementaires
quand vous êtes dans le monde a unique
comme ça c'est de rester connecté cc1 d
une des notions vous vous servez défi
j'ai des questions là-dessus justement
est-ce que vous vous sentez est ce que
vous sentez déconnecté quand vous êtes à
paris dans le 5e arrondissement au
palais du luxembourg sous les ors de la
république
vous vous sentez éloignées du territoire
de leyme de sa réalité vous avez
l'impression qu'il ya une déconnexion au
sénat ou qu'au contraire c'est une
institution peuple et d'élus locaux qui
quand même un briquet sur terre c'est
cesser c'est une institution plutôt
composé largement d'élus extrêmement
connecter aux territoires cédés venturi
les longs parcours d'élu d'élus locaux
non c'est plutôt c'est plutôt une
assemblée très connecté je pense que
c'est moins le cas mais c'est pas une
critique c'est comme ça je pense que
c'est moins qu'à l'assemblée nationale
notamment sur tous ceux qui ont été élus
dans la vague du
président de la république les années
aux députés ça peut faire souffrir un
vent frais qui est sympa je vois mais je
suis moins sûr que sur le commercial au
national et que marquis voulez-vous
demander puisque vous êtes un
relativement jeune sénateur qu'est ce
qui vous surprend le plus dans le
fonctionnement du sénat après ses six
premiers mois
je veux dire autrement est ce que quand
vous êtes arrivé vous vous a dit je
débarque dans un truc qui va sentir la
naphtaline avec que des vieux et je vais
pas être à ma place en tant que jeune ba
c'est cliché non mais c'est le cliché
ouais bon ça fait 12 ans que j'ai eu le
plaisir d'interviewer des sénateurs et
sénatrices je me rends compte que c'est
pas tout à fait vrai avec le cliché est
loin d'être mais justement
dites moi vous vous avez été élu vous
débarquez en juillet sa tante dernier
bon ouais c'est comment le sénat alors
moi le truc c'est que je n'ai jamais
fait d'études de droit
ouais je n'ai jamais été assistant
parlementaire je donc tout le volet
législatif
j connaissez pas énormément quoi donc
j'ai dû j'ai dû m'adapter à tout ça
n'ont ils rien qui m'a vraiment surpris
mais vous savez après il faut voir que
le coc vide
bref est carrément je retourne ma dit le
restaurant du sénat sais comment c'est
sympa les gens pas testé région et la
lumière ouvert un matin elle était
fermée le midi je n'ai jamais nommé est
pour les moments de ces mêmes pas de
convivialité un restaurant c'est
l'exemple mais nouveau vialli t on par y
passer du temps avec les autres pas trop
quoi je m'assois dans un truc ont
éloigné de m on a tous des masques donc
de ce côté là j'ai pas encore pratiqué
mais j'espère que le train de sénateur
ce n'est pas encore ça mais c'est à
cause du comité les trains quelle est sa
vitesse comme on est assis tout ça mais
oui répond quand trop vieux ok d'accord
évidemment vous j'ai plusieurs questions
pour vous de la part des internautes sur
la question de la ruralité et fit police
voulez vous demander qu'est ce que vous
pensez de l'exode des urbains vers le
vert le vert là
réalité depuis le creux vide est-ce que
vous dans l'aisne vous avez vu arriver
c'est et néo-ruraux ces urbains qui sont
venus se confiner au vert moi là où je
suis j'habite j'en ai quelques uns mais
c'est un phénomène
pas plus que ça non c'est un phénomène
limité je crois d'ailleurs que si on
regarde c'est plutôt la normandie la
bretagne c'est plutôt ce territoire où
les way où les parisiens sont allés à la
marge à la marge
qu'est ce que vous pensez que le
développer ses paroles ils peuvent venir
voir les bienvenus est-ce que vous
pensez que le développement du
télétravail va encourager ce ce ce
retour c'est cet exode urbain encore une
fois dans les années qui viennent on
pensait pas qu'on va voir un
repeuplement des déserts rural j'en sais
rien c'est une question je n'ai pas de
réponse mais tout cas il est évident que
le télétravail va modifier beaucoup de
choses
c'est quand même probable qu
effectivement pour bon nombre de
personnes ça change la donne
et alors que ce soit un exode massif
peut-être pas mais en tout cas qu'ils
aient les profils
certains métiers qu'on ne vivait pas
dans l'aisne par exemple qui arrive
c'est pas possible je me méfie toujours
de ces moments où on dit bams est parti
il se passe ça ça met un mouvement de
masse on verra comme reckless voulez
vous demander comment est-ce que vous
concevez le fait d'apporter la ruralité
au sénat est ce que dit ce que vous
sentez que la réalité à sa place au
sénat où est ce que c'est un truc très
parisienne au parisien alors le sénat si
vous voulez parler de la ruralité
si vous voulez faire exister les sujets
de la ruralité c'est juste le bon
endroit il ya d'ailleurs alors une sur
représentation du monde rural
c'est ce qui fait la spécificité la
spécificité du sénat donc pour parler
des sujets qui concernent la ruralité le
cfc juste le bon truc là ok comment est
ce que vous dites là cadieux qui voulez
vous demander comment est-ce que vous
concevez le développement de la 5g en
france alors que certains territoires ne
sont toujours pas couverts par la fibre
optique notamment
vous savez le show c'est quelque chose
que je dont je parle souvent de belles
je sais c'est pour ça que je pose la
question vous avez beaucoup agi en tant
qu'élu local pour équiper en fibre
optique votre terrine en sait quelque
chose qui est plutôt pas mal marché
alors racontez moi d'ailleurs si on peut
parler d'un sujet technique quitté fois
pas être nommé l'aménagement du
territoire l'aménagement du territoire
ça veut dire quoi déjà ça veut dire quoi
c'est que c'est les services que vous
avez dans le territoire c'est quoi les
voies de communication c'est quoi votre
réseau téléphonique
c'est quoi votre débit internet c'est
quoi les médecins vous avez donné de
chez vous l'aménagement sur
l'aménagement du territoire l'état il ya
quelques années grands aménageurs du
territoire ou dit je vais déployer la
fibre dans la france donc elle se met à
parler que les grands opérateurs
la vérité c'est qu'ils se concentrent
sur des secteurs extrêmement urbain pour
des raisons qu'on peut parfaitement
comprendre quand vous déroulez 100
mètres de câbles dans le 5e
arrondissement vous fait 300 foyers
c'est rentable quand vous faites sur
mètres de câbles crécy-sur-serre vous
faites trois maisons c'est moins
rentables le qu'ils y viennent pas hélas
la fin les territoires se sont organisés
dans l'aisne
mais comme beaucoup d'autres ce sont des
élus locaux dans des structures qui sont
allés chercher les financements il est
ami des rondes ailleurs à la fin qui
sont allés comment qui ont monté ces
dossiers de manière très opérationnelle
très technique et dans un département
comme l'aisne vous avez aujourd'hui 80%
des foyers qui sont raccordés à la fibre
donc c'est un truc qui marche plutôt
bien et on voit que c'est comme ça que
ça doit fonctionner l'aménagement du
territoire et la décentralisation
les élus locaux dites nous quelles sont
les priorités opéraient les choses et
moi étage mais de l'argent pour vous
accompagner
c'est comme ça que ça doit fonctionner
et ce à cette articulation là elles
marchent plutôt bien sur le territoire
sur la fibre optique c'est un exemple
qui fait que ça enfin ce qui prouve que
ça fonctionne quand on fait comme ça
donc c'est un côté confiance aux élus
locaux qui savent mieux que l'état où se
placent les choses dans les synthèses à
ce que ça donnerait des leçons sur
d'autres sujets je pense que vite par
exemple mais est exactement c'est on
fait confiance aux élus locaux on vous
accompagne et on met les moyens
financiers ouais d'accord
une piscine parce que parce que les
problématiques sont pas les mêmes dans
l'aisne la problématique c'est pas la
même que dans le 5ème que sur le vieux
port à marseille au fin fond de
l'ardèche quoi chacun ses priorités
chacun a ses sujets et qu'est-ce qui
vous connecte à ça ce sont les élus
locaux
d'ailleurs 40 qui sert quand le
gouvernement parle de nouvel acte de
décentralisation vous voyez ça d'un bon
oeil vous voyez vous pensez que le
gouvernement va aller dans ce sens sur
les mots oui si je me réfère à ce qui
est indiqué dans la cadre d akkad des je
précise pour ceux qui nous écoutent
c'est vrai nom de cette loi de
décentralisation la nouvelle loi
voilà qui est attendu mais ça m'a pas
l'air d'aller très loin
sans vouloir faire là mais critique vous
faire beaucoup la donne pourrait normes
ce et des adaptations ce sont des
adaptations à la marge
alors qu'est ce qu'il faudrait changer
c'est quoi le big bang territorial qu'il
faudrait faire mais le big bang déjà il
faut comprendre que c'est pas moi je
suis pas dans un truc où c'est la guerre
entre les ruraux et les urbains
quand on vit dans un pays c'est la
france le but du jeu c'est que chacun là
où il est trouvent les services qui
correspondent au lieu de vie que vous
choisissez
et le fonctionnement l'articulation
c'est ce que je vous disais c'est
contractualiser par département que
l'état contre accusé par département les
priorités et accompagne les choix et les
priorités des élus et que l'état ne
s'est pas d'appliquer les mêmes
politiques partout mais c'est parce que
l'état il fonctionne comme ça à la
sortie de la deuxième guerre mondiale
l'état aménager le territoire mais
globalement il fallait à peu près
partout la même chose il fallait des
services de l'état il fallait de la voix
il fallait de la route il fallait du
rail et donc on a déployé partout la
même chose
et globalement ça a marché sauf qu'entre
temps il et territoires qui ont eu des
vies différentes et les priorités elles
vont changer
d'accord ok une question de cyanide sur
sur la question de la mutation des
filières agricoles
est ce que vous pensez qu'à l'avenir le
visage de nos campagnes va radicalement
changer alors vous parlez quoi de
l'agriculture on parle d'agriculture la
transition écologique notamment la
transition vers vers faire plus de bio
vers la gestion de la biodiversité est
ce que est ce que l'on n'est as qu'on
est à l'aune d'une révolution agricole
ou pas et l'agriculture elle est en
révolution depuis dix ans
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il faut avoir
l'esprit jeu quand on parle de la
pollution de l'agriculture extensive
pour faire court oui intensité mais
attend s'ils ouais c'est 40 pour enfin
le l'utilisation de produits nocifs
c'est une baisse de 40% en disant j'ai
pas certain qu'ils aient beaucoup de
professions qui ai vécu ça et ça avance
et ça avance dans ce sens là il faut
laisser le temps aux choses mais c'est
quand on est sur le sujet du glyphosate
ou des néonicotinoïdes déjà il faut voir
ça de manière rationnelle
parce que des fois on peut mettre des
images sortir des choses qui font que
l'on soit baraque d'un coup mais faut
mettre un peu de rationalité un peu de
rationalité là dedans vous pouvez pas
demander à quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui a acheté une voiture
diesel il ya quelques mois qu'il utilise
matin et soir pour aller bosser vous
pouvez pas faire une loi pour lire
ecoute dans six mois diesel c'est
terminé et vous dire tellement j'ai fait
des prêts chez lesquels mettent à faire
tous les jours je fais comment on laisse
le temps en test le temps de s'adapter
et il faut laisser le temps
l'agriculture de le faire et
l'agriculture
elle est vraiment en train de faire un
chef ferrer pardon est ce que ça vous
inquiète de voir le nombre
d'agriculteurs diminué d'année en année
c'est l'agriculture vit ce qu'on a vécu
dans beaucoup de vent beaucoup de métier
si vous voulez pour eux pour gagner sa
vie pour faire court comme agriculteur
là il vous fallait 100 hectares et
quelques années aujourd'hui vous enfants
300 dont vous avez des phénomènes de
concentration
là où il vous fallait 50 par l'enfer
détails mais là où il vous fallait 50
vaches laitières il vous en faut 150
aujourd'hui pour équilibrer les choses
donc lé phénomène de concentration qui
ont lieu dans l'agriculture il y en a
pas un phénomène al'inverse de réduction
de la taille des parcelles une
agriculture différente qui permet
d'avoir un meilleur rendement nettement
je sais pas si c'est vraiment la
question que je vous pose
non aujourd'hui aujourd'hui pas plus que
ça alors venez qui sont sur des
exploitations de beaucoup plus petit qui
part sur des cultures extrêmement bio
mais aujourd'hui est ce qu'on vit de
d'une culture totalement bio ça modèle
économique qui n'est pas encore posée
déjà il ya peu de producteurs ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que il ya plus de
production que de consommateurs
aujourd'hui dans le bio
donc c'est un équilibre économique
aujourd'hui pas simple pas simple à
trouver du côté du consommateur du coup
qu'il faudrait agir en gros en incitant
considérablement à l'achat de hobyo pour
permettre à des filières agricoles d'en
vivre oui mais il faut y
mais il faut que les gens aient le
pouvoir d'achat pour pouvoir acheter les
bijoux le service noir quel est votre
avis sur le pesticide dont le combat
pour l'écologie vous l'avez abordé tout
à l'heure la question vous avez dit
qu'il fallait donner du temps au temps
je pensais que les écolos veulent aller
trop vite moi les écolos faut fouiller
il ya une galaxie des écolos il y en a
qui sont extrêmement virulent je je je
j'ai dû mal entendre déjà faut
comprendre que l'agriculteur c'est le
premier qui est exposé à la pollution et
je pense que c'est lui qui utilisent les
produits donc déjà lui en premier lieu
je pense qu'il souhaite forcément qu'on
soit sur des produits plus plus plus
dans le développement durable
mais votre question pardon c'était sur
les écolos veulent et trop vite ouais il
faut comprendre que l'agriculture
elle fait des efforts alors je dis
pauvre en trouver un ou deux d'ici là
qu'il est fort mais vraiment elle est
dans cette dynamique là et donc il faut
l'accompagner il faut la soutenir
il faut lui laisser le temps de
s'organiser et c'est quelque chose qu'on
fait pas assez aujourd'hui penser que je
trouve que le ministre dormandy depuis
qu'il est arrivé
ouais a bien compris l'équation est
qu'il est qu il est plutôt là dedans
mais j'ai encore va du coup la même
question mais ça on a déjà abordé thaler
sur le rôle de l'élu local dans le
développement économique des territoires
notamment dans les zones rurales non
mais ça ça on a déjà abordé cette
question là attendez excusez moi parce
que là j'ai une question qui remonte
oui sur la question de l'accès au
numérique des seniors est ce que vous
pensez et ce que vous pensez que
l'équipement des foyers est quelque
chose qui va accélérer la possibilité
pour les seniors d'avoir accès au
numérique et à l'internet dans les
territoires ruraux
alors aujourd'hui si vous êtes dans un
département comme laine ou soie un
territoire où je suis élue
la fibre et devant chez vous maintenant
la question c'est est ce que je leur
accorde
ouais et la question c'est quelles sont
les usages à quoi est-ce que ça peut ça
peut me servir
et ça c'est tout une inaction qu'elle
n'est d'ailleurs par beaucoup de
collectivités qui est de sensibilisation
à l'utilisation du numérique
donc ça dépend quand même quel âge vous
avez mais en tout cas il ya tout un tas
de choses bien en termes de dépendance
les gens qui vivent chez eux qu'ont
besoin d'être d'être aidés quoi il ya
tout un tas de choses que lui mais rick
va permettre de faire pour avoir des
capteurs sur un frigo est ce qu'il est
ouvert tous les deux trois jours enfin
voilà savoir si la personne va bien si
de ce côté là il ya pas mal de choses à
faire
à présent c'est un peu plus jeunes ouais
il ya tout des actions de
sensibilisation et de formation qui sont
lancés par les uns par les uns et les
autres
donc les accords mets et du coup ça mais
il faut garder un oeil numérique c'est
très bien la fibre optique c'est très
bien ça facilite la vie ça permet plein
de choses par contre il ya tout un pan
de la population
lille électro nisme alors qu'ils
touchent quand même un certain nombre de
personnes dans la population
ces gens là il faut continuer à avoir
des services en chair et en os parce que
on peut pas les laisser sans rien donc
le le service public et les services en
général le numérique
ok on rencontre il faut continuer à voir
quelque chose d'humain con
qu'est ce que vous pensez du coût des
maisons france connect de cette idée de
cette idée de francs services exclusifs
à part dont l'idée du gouvernement de
rassembler sur un guichet unique
différents services publics au niveau
local pour vous c'est un assèchement du
service public il faudrait au contraire
avoir plus de guichets mais globalement
les services publics eau beaucoup reculé
en réalité ces dernières années parce
que l'état ne sait plus réellement
emporté service public et donc en clair
alors c'est un coup de com génial ans
ils appellent ça les maisons france
service la vérité c'est que ce sont des
maisons qui sont payés aménager des gens
qui sont rémunérés par les collectivités
locales les dom et un peu de trucs à
l'amorçage mais c'est les collectivités
qui gèrent et qui financièrement
prennent en charge les choses mais alors
il ya ce transfert de charges ou c'est
les communes qui vont faire les
collectivités locales qui vont assumer
une charge qu'elle n'avait pas en lieu
et place de l'étape
ça c'est la difficulté par contre leur
capacité à rendre un service est un
service de meilleure qualité j'en suis à
peu près convaincu sur des modèles fixe
d'accueil sur des modèles itinérant qui
tourne dans les communes c'est quelque
chose qui peut qui peut qui peut
apporter des services qui avait plus aux
réalités
ok d'accord avec ce point de vue là sans
victoire organisée et financée par les
collectivités locales
j'avais une question sur la chasse qui
vous est posée puisque il ya quelques
jours il ya une tribune qui a été
cosignée par une centaine de
personnalités demandant l'abolition de
la chasse à courre pour contre la chasse
à courre alors bien géré je n'ai jamais
participé à des chasses à courre
ouais je sais que pour beaucoup c'est
quelque chose de très traditionnel
et quand ils m'en parlent plus que j'ai
l'occasion d'échanger avec des gens qui
la pratiquent
il en parle avec beaucoup de enfin voila
c'est quelque chose de très traditionnel
donc j'y suis jamais allé je connais pas
alors j'ai vu quelques images qui sont
des fois avec effectivement plutôt ce
qui est plutôt choquant mais il faut pas
faire celui qui répond pas mais le jour
où j'aurai vu j'aurais compris pourquoi
et comment ça se passe je vous
apporterai une réponse comme la
convention citoyenne fois les voir quoi
mais faut pas juger de prime abord ce
que sont les traditions et les habitudes
des uns et des autres il faut essayer
d'aller voir et comprendre et c'est ce
qu'il faut que je sois sur ce sujet non
mais c'est bien aimé d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce qu est ce que vous
sentez que en tant que sénateur il ya un
certain nombre de sujets comme ça sur
lesquels vous vous pensez que vous
manquez de de billes de compréhension et
vous auriez besoin d'aller rencontrer
plus de gens est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous pouvez faire votre mandat
mais il ya mille sujets comme ça et
d'ailleurs je je je je je m'astreins des
cas alors pas tous parce qu'on peut pas
le faire mais sur un certain nombre de
sujets sur lesquels où je dois
intervenir ou qui passent en commission
mais je m'astreins mais je le fais
plaisir à prendre le téléphone ou à
prendre ma voiture est allée rencontrer
des gens qui sont directement concernés
par les choses et en général j'essaie de
prendre deux sons de cloche c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui est plutôt pour expliquer
plutôt contre et ça vous ouvre les yeux
sur pas mal
enfin sur le sujet mais c'est
intéressant parce que vous risquez
est-ce que vous pensez que le que faire
parce que vous êtes sénateur depuis
depuis quelques mois est ce que vous
pensez que vous allez être amené à vous
prononcer sur un nombre incalculable de
textes sur des sujets très différents
les uns des autres y compris sur des
sujets sur lesquels vous en savez vous
en savez pas grand chose quoi et on peux
pas vous en vouloir c'est ce que vous
dites c'est un peu difficile en tant que
sénateur de devoir se prononcer sur des
textes comme ça tous les jours
mais il ya une partie qui est frustrante
ouais
moi je me suis exprimé hier sur
l'adaptation du marché du courtage en
assurances bon voilà enfin la base c'est
pas les allergies un petit peu travaillé
non mais c'est pas beau ça
je maîtrise le mieux c'est pas forcément
le truc que je lis tous les soirs c'est
pascal qui passionne de swiss sont bons
non mais il ya beaucoup de sujets et on
peut pas tous les maîtriser et c'est le
grand reproche qui est fait de dire on
voit pas grand monde dans l'hémicycle en
voix mais c'est parce que vous êtes
obligé un brin de vous spécialiser ou de
vous attaquer à certains sujets plus
qu'à d'autres et vous pouvez pas avoir
la connaissance de tous voilà
et comment juger qui passe il est
extrêmement important et comment vous
avez décidez vous votre spécialisation
ça s'est passé comment hommes et moi je
suis assez simple je le fais à l'envi
je l'aménagement du territoire c'est la
commission je suis rentré parce que
c'est des sujets qui concernent plus
directement la ruralité après il ya des
sujets qui passera par tout ce qui
concerne l'audiovisuel les gars fox cg
qui m'intéresse parce que je lis là
dessus rien des reportages là dessus eh
ben je comme ça passe je me lis
intéresse je participe aux débats que
c'est un pendentif à l'envi vous écouter
vous avez bien raison faut pas se forcer
vous connaissiez twitch ou pas je
connaissais et twitch mais je n'étais
jamais allé sur twitch j'ai lu des
articles sur twitter ouais j'ai déjà
téléchargé tweet jamais leurs patients
de s'inscrire et
il ya sûrement triple strasbourg ouais
je connaissais le principe mais je n'en
étais pas utilisateurs ok ok bon vous le
deviendrez peut-être en tout cas vous
avez dit que les sujets sont aussi je me
demande à la chaîne d'information matin
midi soir
et merci vous avez bien raison mais non
mais du coup le les sujets audiovisuels
vous intéresse vous voyez aussi des
mutations dans ce secteur là vous voyez
que les choses bougent s'est déchaînée
sur lesquels vous avez envie de
travailler au sénat ouais au sénat et
peut-être même oui c'est les sujets que
c'est des sujets qui m'intéressent
beaucoup parce que derrière ça il ya
énormément de choses le modèle qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui l'audiovisuel alors
au delà
d'ailleurs c'est tout un secteur
économique à avoir la production de
téléfilms d'émissions télé de gens que
ça fait vivre
faut voir derrière le financement du
cinéma faudra d'ailleurs le financement
du sport il ya un modèle économique qui
qui qui qui qui est extrêmement
important pour la société franklin peut
ravager en ce moment par ailleurs et qui
est totalement faux billets en tout cas
extrêmement remis en cause par de
nouveaux modes de consommation les
netflix et amazon enfin les fameuses
plateformes k sur pareil on peut dire
hein c'est pas bien c'est bon c'est
comme ça donc il faut il faut revoir les
choses déjà en termes de législation
c'est à dire que ces chaînes de
télévision ces modèles ils ont des
parements pas débouler au pied m'enfin
de réglementation assez contraignante et
leurs impôts en france et d'autres ils
paient pas d'impôts enfin quasiment pas
d'impôt et réglementations 0 ça peut
juste sur un plan réglementaire pas du
tout fonctionné comme ça et c'est pareil
sur l'orientation des financements faut
encore voir les choses mais on joue
beaucoup de choses derrière ça
absolument mais y compris en termes de
souveraineté de souveraineté du pays la
souveraineté culturelle la france et
paris en termes de culture
enfin je
je vois qu'il faut il faut aller sur les
planches au pub mais faut aller sur les
plateformes on se rend compte de la
diversité de ce qui se fait dans ce pays
en terme de série de fautes
enfin c'est un secteur économique et
c'est une vraie densité français sous
forme bat pour ça vous avez raison ça
soulève des sujets suivants passionnant
vous savez la plateforme switch par
exemple appartient amazon d'accord voilà
il ya une production française et
unibail ici on est un show de production
de démission tout s'est donc il ya un
savoir faire français et pour autant
c'est une plateforme qui appartient à la
zone donc c'est vrai que ça pose des
questions de souveraineté ça ça pose des
questions le loin d'être négligeable
mais c'est intéressant entre quelques
dès que des sénateurs s'intéresse à ces
mutations et et vous avez parfaitement
parfaitement raison
donc là à suivre aussi j'espère vous
réinterroger les choses sur lesquelles
je vais passer du temps ben je souhaite
c'est des dernières questions à vous
poser on arrive bientôt à la fin de
cette émission sur plus spécifiquement
le coc vide l'autre grand sujet de
l'année qui vient de s'écouler
est-ce que vous commencez à en voir la
fin du coc vide penser que l'été va se
passer comment non mais j'en sais rien
mais comme tout comme tout français j'ai
une version allégée croire à tout ça
quand on en parle mais je sais pas je ne
sais pas josé j'ose espérer mais voilà
j'ose espérer que les vaccins arrivent
en masse enfin j'ai beaucoup de mal à
croire l'objectif des 50 millions là
dans quelques dans quelques mois mais
bon enfin que
que ça arrive le plus vite possible
qu'on puisse au maximum reprendre une
existence normale que beaucoup ont
beaucoup d'élus locaux ont critiqué les
relations difficiles avec les services
de l'état dans la gestion du dans la
gestion du conflit d'une manière
générale aujourd'hui c'est la
vaccination hier c'était les tests vous
sur le terrain dans l'aisne ça s'est
passé comment avec l' agence régionale
de santé avec le préfet jean castex nous
parler du couple maires préfets ça s'est
passé comment mais alors déjà tous
incarnent dans des dents des femmes dans
des hommes brunet question c'est déjà le
sait déjà le premier sujet mais le
problème de l'état de la rsc pas la
volonté des uns et des autres de bien
faire c'est que c'est un peu le triangle
des bermudes c'est qu'on sait pas bien
quand on comprend pas bien qui décide
qui a la main qui à l'information qui ne
va pas et ça la difficulté parce que
avoir un échange vous l'avez mais quand
on sait pas vous répondre aux commandes
monsieur x qui y fut même c'est pas
qu'il doit en référer y qui c'est ça la
difficulté et le dentaire d'en parler de
la décentralisation
moi je suis pour renforcer le pouvoir
des préfets que tout ce qui concerne les
actions départementales et le rôle de
l'état soit dans la main des préfets
vous avez quelqu'un qu'elle a qui sur
tous les sujets enfin tous grande partie
des sujets peux vous dire oui non
pourquoi sais comment c'est pourquoi on
gagnerait beaucoup en termes de 2,2 de
rapidité dans la chance avec l'état à
vous les y attendait voulait dire
augmenter les pouvoirs du préfet par
rapport à l'état central cirque le
préfet arrête d'attendre des heures de
paris par rapport à l'état central qu'il
ait la main sur la grèce qu'ils aient la
main sur les services culturels qui les
voit l' elysée que par exemple que les
rs puisqu'on parle beaucoup d'elle dans
la cadre de lutte contre le coc vide
soit placé sur la sincérité des conseils
régionaux vous êtes favorable ou pas
compétence à hiré giono when you l'idée
qu'une compétence d'une compétence
sanitaires non concernés c'est quelque
chose qui relève de
l'état parce que qu'ils aient une vision
nationale et que chaque français alors
même si ce n'est pas la réalité mais
maintenant on avoir le même accès au
soin ça me paraît non c'est une action
qui doit qui doit rester étatique mais
qui par contre nous à l'échelle
départementale est sous l'autorité des
préfets ou à l'échelle régionale way une
question d'amadeus qui vous demandent
est ce que en tant que maire vous vous
vous êtes senti impuissant face à la
gestion de la crise du coc vide parce
qu'on a eu l'impression de vous voir là
on a vu des mères face caméra expliqué
qu' on n'en peut plus on voit les gens
qui n'y arrive pas on voit les gens qui
aiment bien se faire tester avoir des
masses demain avoir des vaccins est ce
que vous sentez que que les maires
manque de capacité d'action mais après
ce sont des caractères et c'est comment
on voit les choses vous allez ceux qui
regardent leurs pompes qui pleure au
verger pas de chance ça va pas bon alors
des gens me faisaient sur un truc c'est
que ça n'ira pas ça vous êtes tranquille
et quand les choses ne s'étaient pas
simple évidemment il y avait tout le
sujet sur les masques sur tout ça mais
j'ai plutôt tendance à essayer de voir
le
r à moitié plein et essayer de résoudre
les choses quand quelqu'un est malade
si vous allez le voir il est vraiment à
pas l'air d'aller bien n'allez pas de
l'aider quoi faut plutôt essayer de
positiver le truc donc qu'il s'agit pas
d'être béat il s'agit pas de regarder
les étoiles en permanence est ce qu on
pourrait vous regardez la réalité
ouais mais il faut regarder la réalité
il faut essayer de tirer d'énergie pour
ça donc je oui il ya eu des moments
difficiles
c'était pas toujours simple mais
globalement on a les uns les autres et
faire le maximum et puis les citoyens se
sont rendus compte
merci beaucoup pierre jean de verges de
m on a déjà fini la pression ça a vite
en 20 minutes pour la bienvenue sur tric
bonjour merci à vous surtout merci
beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette émission
merci pierre jean vazel end avoir
accepté mon invitation merci à vous vous
pouvez retrouver sur public sénat le
canal 13 de la tnt
passez une bonne fin de journée la
semaine prochaine ciao
[Musique]